this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode he's going to be
checking out the weapons of milsim
shooter armor reforger okay it looks
like they're not yet modeling the actual
rocket inside the tube but hey you're
only going to spot that if you go into
photo mode and look down the front or
stupidly stand in front of your teammate
and look down his uh anti-tank weapon
make sure to check out our previous
episode on the firearms of arma 3 and
while you're there subscribe for more
videos just like this and if there are
any other games guns or mechanics that
you guys want to see jonathan break down
let us know in the comment section below
right over to jonathan
so right away the realism kind of hits
you in the face and the ears because the
uh the sound of near misses from bullets
it's almost like watching combat footage
to a degree as much of a degree as as is
possible basically with the game you can
instantly tell that this is much more of
a simulation than other games like call
of duty it's the obvious comparison the
rifle i'm seeing here is the m16a2 the
actual usgi as it were m16a2
the adjustable rear sights the heavy
barrel so the ca2 really looks like
they've nailed it i can't think of
anything really to criticize here i
don't know if they've modeled the burst
fire correctly such that if you come off
the trigger too soon you'll end up with
either two or one rounds in your next
burst i'll watch a bit more and see if
that eventuates
it might not but it's a genuine
complaint of this rifle burst fire
that's the other aspect of the
american
issue
1016 a2 so this game i did have to look
it up this game takes place in 1989 this
rifle was only introduced to the us army
which is the the force being represented
here in 1986 and even then not every
unit got it right away so although
whilst we'd probably be seeing a twos if
we're gonna nitpick and i have to
because i can't find anything else to
complain about the wear on this rifle it
seems a bit excessive for three years
service we've got high point wear on the
uh this lump here where the cam pin
rotates into on the inside of the gun
that's what this is for we've got where
on the carry handle where on the
magazine well now our example has got
the beginnings of wear through to the
aluminium or aluminum if you prefer
around here and admittedly it's probably
seen almost no use but still a bit too
warm that's the best i can come up with
guys
i do i do like the way that this is not
exclusive to this game by any means but
the way the iron sights move relative to
each other as you move around it used to
be if you had iron sights in the game
they'd be a fixed sight picture and
they'd never move relative to the
movement of the player it just it adds a
little bit of realism and also that's
that rear sight so that's the that's the
close combat type aperture that is
visible just like on the screen both of
them are fully enclosed by the sight
protectors that's why they're called
site protectors but the number of games
that get that wrong and have the
the m16 or air 15 site sticking above
the the ears here is at least several
that do that and what would happen if
you drop it deform your rear sight and
suddenly your shots are landing where
you where you're placing them reloading
animations absolutely fine as far as i'm
concerned a pitfall for a game like this
that's going back in time 30 odd years
is that you end up using anachronistic
animations or all positions and holds of
what weapons as well because training
has changed quite a bit even since 1989
so you're not necessarily going to well
you're not going to see john wick flicks
of magazine or even pressing the
pressing the magazine catch and letting
the magazine fall out i'm sure that was
done i'm pretty sure it wasn't taught so
you probably would be removing the
magazine with your off hand any veterans
who surf with these of course defer to
you on that one but to me this looked
plausible for that i suspect they have
looked at the drill manuals hopefully
involved some veterans as well
all right we've got the m203
our only 203s are on a1s very obviously
they replace the
handguard and they have a simple tangent
sight you adjust vertically and then aim
up to compensate so here what we're
seeing is the the solder is aiming
roughly an angle and i i gather at least
in vietnam they would use a bit of
instinct and experience in aiming but uh
what you're supposed to do is flip the
site up and aim using the sight
obviously you've only got so many of
these rounds and you want them to land
where you want them to go so i assume
that's a feature that will be
implemented later on though that would
be too much of an oversight to be
accidental
we've got the beretta m9 recently
introduced at this time came in 85
onwards if i remember rightly to the us
forces we don't have an m9 per se
annoyingly one of one of many
us general issue
variants of things that we do have but
we don't if that makes sense to you so
anyway this is the
m9
in civilian form so it's the m92 f and
this flush or flat dust cover here is a
feature of the usm9 you might be able to
spot an m9 or at least spot something
that's wrong in a game if it has the
angle dust cover
of later civilian 92 fss but this is the
the broad type and one minor technical
issue i noticed is when this
pistol ran out of ammunition so
locked open on the empty magazine the
trigger was in the forward position
uh in theory ready for double action
fire whereas in fact it should be toward
the rear of the trigger guard because
the weapons cocked because the slide is
over the top of the hammer the reload
might look a bit bit janky to those of
us used to modern uh call of duty
battlefield games and
games of that ilk where they're they're
using or referencing modern tactical
reloading techniques the fact that he is
assisting the magazine out with finger
and thumb and then kind of inserting it
like this unsupported and then slapping
it in
exactly what you've seen at the time
now this is a specific variant of the
m14 that we don't have and i don't have
any real experience of but it is the m21
about the only thing i can say
intelligently about this that isn't
readily available elsewhere is that it
gets described as the m21 sniper weapon
system now i'm a bit of a fan of the
main culture and ethnology and words and
stuff
and i as far as i know that was only
applied to the m24 and it's one of these
things where this was the m21 sniper
rifle and they were looking for a
whiz-bang new name for the new program
and that's where sniper weapon system
came in so i think it's being required
applied sorry retrospectively for this
in terms of what it is if you don't know
the m14 you need to get yourself a gun
book it's although very short
short-lived only i think seven years in
front line service lots of soldiers
really really liked it for its stopping
power range ability to penetrate like
cover and that kind of thing and it made
an awful lot of sense to become the next
sniper rifle for the us army when
you have a rifle firing quite a
lightweight cartridge in the m16 to have
something more powerful and longer
ranged well we have thousands of these
things in the armories let's get them
out let's get them set up with a good
scope and the m21 was born so it's
actually an automatic m14 with the
selector removed but then nearly all
m14s did have the select remove so that
in itself doesn't make it an m21 really
being selected for accuracy and having
the scope mount the receiver tapped for
the scope mount having a scope mount
having the scope and the markings that's
what makes it m21
right we've got the the m249 again but
it's in a highly appropriate context as
the standard us army scored automatic
weapon which is the
tactical niche that the m249 was adopted
to fill it is a light machine gun
in a technical definition but it's a
scored automatic weapon or perhaps a
light support weapon in other countries
terminology in its tactical name well
well done as far as i can tell we've got
some clipping issues with the the user's
face and the stock which is clearly not
intentional i'm sure he's going to be
addressed recoil looks right the way it
handles the rate of fire it's it's hard
to get this thing this thing wrong at
this point it's it's a video game staple
as much as it is a military one although
somewhat controversial in military use
depending on which armed force you're
talking about and when currently not in
use for the british armed forces it's
still in the inventory but i don't
believe it's being fielded and our
forces ended up bringing back the the
big brother equivalent to the american
m240 the l7 at the squad level because
the first we tried to replace that with
the lsw the the sa-80 the l86 a1 and a2
and then they tried to bring in the
belgian minime which is of course what
this is and that kind of sort of seemed
to be working it was very impressive and
gucci but wasn't necessarily as accurate
as it needed to be or as reliable as it
needed to be in that situation you know
us force is still using it it's the
latest thing in the inventory at this
time or not the latest thing but one of
them and it's not the only machine gun
in the game so we'll move on
right we've got a russian machine gun
here should be recognizable to all of
you it's the pkm excellent weapon
lightweight accurate enough powerful
enough relatively low maintenance it's
the classic um spitfire measurement
argument or you know between this and
the
fn mag the 240 the l7 western forces
will tend to say that the gpmg is best
the eastern european countries for
example would probably say that the dkm
is best and now you can decide for
yourself by shooting at each other in
this highly realistic video game the the
249 doesn't barely move at all which is
pretty realistic it's a not heavy
machine gun by any means but it's a
sufficient weight to help keep that
lightweight cartridge on target stark
contrast with the pkm which is
relatively light for a full power
machine gun general purpose which is
what it really is
here used in the light machine gun roll
and there's a significant climb there
the the players having to compensate um
presumably with the mouse so lots of
lots of climb you'd expect that so you
could use this rambo style from the here
and the lord knows it's been done many
times usually not by trained soldiers
but uh you are going to struggle to keep
it on targets without a lot of practice
and of course not very efficient in
ammunition terms
i'm sure this isn't the first thing to
do this by any means but it's the first
time i've noticed it and that's the
realistic feed of the belt the belt
isn't just like like artificially going
into the side of the gun it looks like
it's getting dragged into the mechanism
which it should be and you see the end
of the belt come out the gun and sorry
come out of the belt box and go into the
gun that might be the most realistic
depiction of belt feed that i've seen
that's nice i have slightly mixed
feelings so we've got the rear sight on
this vpn being adjusted so the slider is
being slid and the ramp is there for
moving up and down so you can clearly
adjust your sights in this game which i
would expect to be honest with you
something a game like this what we don't
see though is the hand reach up and do
that adjustment we're not there yet not
not with this game
adjustment of sights in a shooter is
very rare sniping games sort of flirt
with that but it's pretty unusual to be
able to change your adjust your adjust
your sights now it seems from the
on-screen information there that that is
described as just zeroing which is not
really the case you're just adjusting
your sights you're not changing your
zero zero is making point of aim and
point of impact coincide so that you can
then use your gun zeroing is not
adjusting the sights for
range or to compensate for other things
like wind
one i'm reliably informed was nicknamed
the pig in service
the usm60. iconic cross civilians in all
sorts of different movies this is its
original configuration as issued back in
vietnam and it was still the standard
light machine gun although they've been
augmented by the m249 as the sport
automatic weapon
in this time period by this point they
were starting to wear out a little bit
and some of the problems that this thing
is a bit infamous for now we're already
creeping in from what i understand you
know it's almost like the us ordnance
saw two very cool wartime german guns
and went what could be cooler well both
of them at once and
we got this thing which had its issue
but it also has has its supporters still
around uh we've got them i say we the
aria i've got them mounted on as door
guns on helicopters or something because
they came with the helicopters there are
more modern versions shorter lighter
more tactically flexible with rails and
so on but for me this is a classic this
is the rambo gun and uh this is a good
good rendition of it it's nice to see a
squad of um cold war era us soldiers
rifleman popping away with their m16a2s
and you've got the squad
machine gunner there with his m60
something i've noticed with a number of
guns in this game i don't think i'm
imagining it is we've got variable rates
of fire so you know when you look up at
the rate of fire of a gun as you do and
it says between
600 and 650 or or even might even be 100
rounds per minute variation well that's
because especially with belt third guns
i have to drag the belt into themselves
there is some variability depending on
ammunition consistency of ammunition
how dirty they are how they're being
held even depending on how they work and
so a real gun does not robotically fire
one shot every 800 rounds per minute
like i said like you know a fixed figure
would indicate so machine guns often do
give a variable rate even even automatic
rifles now it's very slightly barely
detectable but i think i can hear it in
this game and that would be the first
time i've noticed that if i'm right
about that that's i think
something to something to celebrate
right ak-74 we've covered well all sorts
of aks by this point including 74s i
don't think i've shown you this one
before there are many like it but this
one is out
this one's dated 1983 so that makes it
pretty bang on correct for this game
still with the wooden
laminate furniture
i.e handguard and buttstock
but for a long time by this point we've
got the
plastic pistol grip and the plastic
follower magazines this is super
detailed and very very well modeled
indeed including down to the recoil i.e
not much because this muzzle break
compensator is is highly effective
prior to the modern raft of western
model devices this was
basically the gold standard for recoil
mitigation in an infantry rifle little
details like the gas block pattern is is
correct um i probably have to go in with
a set of virtual calipers to try and
like find fault with this it's it's spot
on right down to the markings on the
trunnion which which are correct
really really good so instead i'll talk
briefly about the sound um
design perhaps to be expected but
the reports it's you know
the guns sound very different to each
other as you might expect certainly
between calibers and then in and out of
enclosed spaces so the the the punch of
that
rifle report as you move into the
building they're audibly very different
dynamic sound is not a new thing by any
means but this game is doing everything
well as far as i can see any like early
build glitches and so on notwithstanding
okay it looks like they're not yet
modeling the actual rockets
inside the tube appears to be an empty
tube and a rocket magically appears from
it but hey you're only going to spot
that if you go into photo mode and look
down the front or stupidly stand in
front of your teammate and look down his
anti-tank weapon the law laws rocket
and 73 bearing i think well we don't
have that but we do have the british
issue version rocket 66 millimeter
heat high explosive anti-tank l1 a1
identical to the us the original issue
us version of the
light entertainment weapon law
has the same firing instructions label
on the side and so very compact
relatively lightweight this is fire and
empty so even more lightweight but
relatively lightweight through an
anti-tank weapon keep it in a pack or
strap to a pack and when you're ready to
use it pull it apart at which point the
compact doesn't really matter your rear
sight flips up front sight flips up
interestingly our front sight is a
different pattern
i don't know enough about the law to
know how significant that is
aiming crosshairs wires
and then
graduated red range markings below it
whereas the variant in the game has
the full window of graduated range
markers
another really good looking gun got the
svd of course i would yeah i'd like to
have a play about with with this in
particular just to see how the the
ranging system in the scope i'm sure
that's all scaled correctly so that you
estimate the height of your target but
therefore work out the range try and
make your first shot count rather than
walking them in like i would tend to do
on something like battlefield now this
is this final shot that we see here with
the looking along the rifle from the
left-hand side i'm sure a lot of you
know this but uh the spd has a bayonet
plug on it but it's designed to take the
bayonet not unique shall we say two
designated marksman rifles the british
army actually looked at a bayonet mount
for the l129 sharpshooter rifle not as
far as i know been fielded but um they
did look at it so being not quite sniper
rifle and not quite an infantry rifle
there are there's an argument for there
being a bayonet log on there it
certainly was in 1963 when this thing
was was introduced
thanks for watching as always guys we
really appreciate it if you'd like to
drop us a donation you're very welcome
to do so via the link in the description
if not or even if so check out our royal
armoury social media channels i've got
twitter instagram and facebook and our
own youtube channel as well thanks very
much guys take care
[Music]
you